66 seconds start the clock
the mummy on the orient express
all right guys low tech in it tonight
i've had another long weekend i don't
have the energy to do the green screen
and this one i don't know what my
expectations were going into it but they
were kind of like ah i i it felt like
filler going in just based on title
alone well it's not it's good solid
stuff now when i say it's not filler
don't think that that's it's pushing you
know the big overarching story this
season no it's not really because as
moffat had made clear in some earlier
comments he meant that this isn't a
continuous story series we we had some
of those with matt smith that this isn't
really what this is this is a bit more
akin to the first few years when we had
eccleston or the first couple with david
10 where we're getting hints of
something that'll factor into the
finales but for the most part it's
self-contained episodes now that's true
but there is a through line going on for
the characters and with the relationship
of the doctor and clara they are going
through steps and going through a
journey so there actually is a
continuous story going on it's just not
the type that we're used to seeing and
this really comes immediately off of
what happened in the last episode with
the two of them and it feels like a
progression towards whatever happens
next and i really kind of like this
approach where any given episode is
fairly self-contained and it's not a
continuing story but there was a
progression with the characters it's
what keeps this episode from feeling
like filler because the characters have
come off of where they were last time
and you feel like there's going to be a
next step for what happens to them in
the next episode but you can still just
watch the episode in isolation and it
makes total sense it's just a really
well balanced episode the setting is
kind of cool is the orient express 20s
style train but in space and there's a
mummy and if you see it which most
people can't but if you do well you're
gonna die in exactly 66 seconds from
when you first see it the whole thing's
got that same kind of fun retro yet
high-tech atmosphere that voyage of the
damned had the supporting cast on this
one is really good there's a number of
standouts although i think my own
personal favorite is uh there's an
engineer character who's just
this subtle unassuming
gem of a character just the way he sort
of takes on what's going on and just his
interactions with the doctor he's very
simple he's very low-key but he's just
he's enjoyable as heck just to have
around and he's not the only one we get
a number of really nice
characterizations that feel well-rounded
you feel the effort and the thought that
the performers put into their characters
and into their backstory and really gave
a very full-bodied performance even for
characters who in some cases only get a
couple of minutes of screen time it's
the sort of feel you get when you watch
a really good stage play there was just
a lot of thought and care put into this
episode and you feel that you feel that
in the writing you feel that in setting
you feel that in the performance i'm
going to stick with what i said last
time about the doctor and clara i like
where they are right now but again not
necessarily in a i hope she never leaves
the tardis kind of way which is what i
felt with characters like donna but in
more of a we're coming to a good
conclusion for her i just kind of feel
that which honestly would be a nice
change of pace it seems like almost
every companion we've had has some sort
of tragic end to their time with the
doctor and it'd be kind of nice to have
something wrap up in a nicer way and it
feels like clara might be headed that
way and it'd be kind of nice i think and
the usual stuff that's good is good the
little bit we get of danny pink again
works very well i just like the way he's
being utilized he's a type of character
at this point that we've seen before in
terms of what his function within the
overall show is but the way his dynamic
plays is different than it has ever been
with that type of character before and i
feel like we're getting that a lot this
series where we're getting stuff that
we've seen before just played
differently and handled differently than
the times we've seen it before and i
think that's just a really good approach
to this series overall because it helps
refresh and so what was old is now new
again and it keeps them from having to
try and reinvent the wheel when they've
got perfectly good stuff that they've
used before they just put a new spin on
it it works again so did you catch this
episode if so let me ask you this one of
the doctor who episodes that have gone
for the sort of early 20th century
aesthetic so i would consider episodes
like this one voyage of the damned which
i mentioned the unicorn and the wasp
even on the outside of that daleks in
manhattan out of those sorts of episodes
with that sort of time feel to them
which one's your own personal favorite
whatever it is drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it until
next time this council is adjourned
you